nous rentrons dans la dernière ligne
droite de nos investigations puisque nos
auditions auront vocation à s'achever
avec le mois de septembre du mois de
nous l'espérons avec monsieur le
rapporteur je crois que nos échanges des
mois de juin et de juillet nos
déplacements accomplis avec le bureau de
la commission d'enquête comme hier à
Sainte-Souline nous donne d'ores et déjà
une vision de plus en plus précise des
exactions qui ont émaillé le printemps
dernier et qui font l'objet plus
spécifique des travaux de notre
commission je rappelle que nous nous
penchons à la fois sur les violences
urbaines essentiellement liés à la
contestation de la réforme des retraites
mais aussi sur les violences en milieu
rural davantage lié à des revendications
que l'on pourrait qualifier
d'environnemental et qui comme nous
l'avons encore vu hier à Sainte Soline
ont pu connaître des poussées d'extrême
violence
nous allons pouvoir désormais confronter
nos intuitions et nos analyses à la
vision des plus hautes autorités de
l'État nous nous réjouissons monsieur le
garde des sceaux de bénéficier de votre
présence devant la commission d'enquête
ce matin merci pour votre présence un
questionnaire vous a préalablement été
transmis par monsieur le rapporteur
Florent Boudier qui est à mes côtés
toutes les questions qu'il contient ne
pourront évidemment pas forcément être
évoqué de manière exhaustive ce matin
sans quoi je pense que la matinée ni
suffirait point mais c'est pas
l'objectif on n'est pas là pour comment
dire
aborder forcément tous ces points en
tout cas je vous invite monsieur le
ministre a communiqué vos réponses
écrites via votre cabinet ainsi que tout
autre information que vous jugeriez
utile de porter à la connaissance de la
commission d'enquête dans la foulée de
cette audition puisque ça sera
extrêmement utile pour le rapport qui
qui sera
avant de vous faire prêter serment comme
le veut l'usage il me revient d'ouvrir
les travaux je le ferai comme à mon
habitude en vous soumettant les deux
premières questions qui permettront déjà
d'engager la discussion et puis ensuite
évidemment je passerai aussi la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur ainsi comment de
la commission d'enquête qui souhaiterait
également vous vous posez des questions
je petites règles on essaye de se tenir
pour les questions à deux minutes donc
je ne veux frustrer absolument personne
mais voilà pour que l'objectif étant que
celles et ceux qui souhaitent intervenir
puissent le faire en premier lieu
monsieur le ministre il semble qu'un des
éléments de fragilité de la réponse de
l'État aux violences en manifestations
une des difficultés les plus fréquemment
pointées en tous les cas réside dans les
injonctions contradictoires auxquelles
sont soumises aussi bien les policiers
que les gendarmes les compagnies et les
escadrons sont déployés dans une de
maintien de l'ordre c'est-à-dire que
première mission qui leur incombe cette
émission de police administrative de
sécurisation des personnes et des biens
au cours des rassemblements d'ailleurs
pour faire en sorte que le droit de
manifester qui est un droit
constitutionnel puisse être respecté
mais avec les premières exactions un
second objectif apparaît assez
naturellement qui est celui de la police
judiciaire de l'interpellation des
auteurs d'infraction et de la collecte
d'épreuves dont les tribunaux devront
disposer pour pouvoir dans un second
temps entrer
si c'est nécessaire on voit de
condamnation nos travaux font apparaître
combien il est délicat pour les
policiers et les gendarmes de remplir
l'une et l'autre mission ce que relève
d'ailleurs le taux très élevé de
classement sans suite d'alternative aux
poursuites et de relax
le maintien de l'ordre suppose la mise à
distance
l'interpellation et la collecte
d'épreuves suppose au contraire d'aller
au contact c'est un peu antinomique
monsieur le garder sceau comment cette
comment peut-on essayer de résoudre
finalement cette forme de quadrature du
cercle puisque d'un côté mise en
distance de l'autre côté il faut aller
chercher de la preuve et de manière
individuelle puisque évidemment dans un
état de droit il faut pouvoir prouver
que la personne a pu commettre telle ou
telle exaction une adaptation de l'amont
de la procédure pénale assez contexte
très particulière est-elle en cours vous
paraît-elle nécessaire puisque les
fiches de liaison utilisées actuellement
ne semblent pas pleinement fonctionner
même si elles ont semble-t-il apporté je
dirais un plus grand formalisme dans la
procédure mais
nous avons pu au cours des auditions
constater que cela se heurtait quand
même encore à quelques difficultés et en
second lieu est plus brièvement le bilan
du droit pénal applicable en
manifestation et pour le moins contrasté
je ne vous apprends rien certaines
innovations récentes fonctionnent
notamment les réquisitions du procureur
de la République pour le contrôle
d'accès au rassemblement ça c'est
quelque chose qui nous avons pu le
constater fonctionne très bien d'autres
disons-le sont un échec la peine
d'interdiction de participer à des
manifestations sur la voie publique ne
semble quasiment pas recevoir
d'applications alors on voit bien les
difficultés quant à l'infraction de
dissimulation de visage l'élément
intentionnel est devenu quasi impossible
à établir depuis la covid-19 puisque
celle-ci a légitimé le fait de se
masquer en toute circonstances est-ce
que vous sachez qu'il est nécessaire
d'adapter le code assez constat et et si
votre réponse est affirmative quelle
serait pour vous des pistes pertinentes
voilà en tout cas quelques éléments sur
lesquels j'aimerais que nous puissions
engager avec la commission d'enquête
notre discussion et je passerai comme je
l'ai indiqué dans un second temps
évidemment la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur à Monsieur le garder sous
avant de vous donner d'ores et déjà la
parole et en application de l'article 6
de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement nos assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité et je vous
prie de lever la main droite et de dire
je le jure après avoir activé votre
micro
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
lorsque
d'autres personnes souhaiteront
intervenir on aura recours à un même
procédure mais en tout cas sans attendre
je vous passe la parole monsieur le
ministre et une nouvelle fois je vous
remercie pour votre présence ce matin
merci monsieur le Président
vous m'avez posé à titre liminaire
trois questions en réalité pas deux mais
trois la première c'est les questions
écrites et le sort que nous comptions
réserver audits alors sous la foi de ce
serment sous son bénéfice
dire que fin de semaine normalement
je j'y ajoute l'adverbe parce que
nous devrions avoir répondu aux
questions que légitimement vous posez
ensuite deux jours de questions sur des
injonctions dont vous dites qu'elles
sont contradictoires entre la police
administrative d'une part et la police
judiciaire d'autre part
je suis pas certain mais nous y
reviendrons bien sûr après mon propos
liminaire que nous soyons dans la
contradiction et en tous les cas si
c'est une contradiction j'ai eu une
contradiction j'ai envie de dire que
elle est juste depuis qu'il existe la
police administrative et la police
judiciaire
et puis enfin vous me demandez si des
choses sont en cours tant je veux
rappeler je vous rappeler monsieur le
Président que il y a une modification de
la procédure pénale à droit constant qui
est en cours des laboration que nous
allons constituer
des que le texte sera entériné un suivi
parlementaire vous pourrez naturellement
postuler c'est une invitation ce n'est
certes pas une injonction car
l'impératif m'est interdit pour suivre
un peu l'évolution des choses et pardon
de vous dire
sans être impertinent que on va aussi
s'inspirer de vos travaux pour voir si
nous devons modifier un peu les règles
je dirais ce qu'a priori j'en pense mais
à la lecture de votre apport il sert
aussi à cela on pourra évidemment
envisager de modifier certains nombre de
choses
alors ce président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs vous avez
rappelé monsieur le Président la trêve
et estivale elle est terminée je suis
ravi en ce qui me concerne de de renouer
avec le Parlement et c'est aussi pour
moi l'occasion de vous souhaiter une
bonne reprise je ne sais pas
quelle est la date de vos reprises
respectives mais en tous les cas qui me
soit permis de vous adresser
vous adresser ses vœux
je vous remercie de m'avoir évidemment
convié à cette
audition et votre commission d'enquête
s'intéresse
juste titre dois-je rajouter à la
connaissance qu'à l'autorité judiciaire
de ces mouvements subversifs
connaissances qu'elle a pu acquérir
grâce à son action quotidienne dans le
traitement de ces débordements depuis
l'interpellation des auteurs jusqu'à
naturellement la réponse pénale
ces derniers mois nous le savons les
rassemblements les manifestations sur la
voie publique ont été le théâtre
d'actes portant
gravement atteinte à l'ordre public
principalement dirigé contre les biens
mais aussi trop souvent bien sûr contre
les forces de l'or et je veux ici
d'abord
les condamnés avec la plus grande
fermeté et vous dire en préambule que
aucune cause aucune
ne peut justifier ces déchaînements de
violence
et
mes symboles de la de la République ont
été atteints
touché un policier un gendarme c'est
évidemment touché à la République et je
veux d'abord redire
mon indéfectible soutien à l'égard des
forces de sécurité intérieure
certains de ces actes sont le fait de
groupuscule violent
et investi les manifestations les ronces
semblent dans l'objectif assumer
de commettre des exactions d'une
particulière brutalité
bien avant les faits du printemps
dernier la France nous le savons et nous
le déplorons mais déjà connu
des faits similaires notamment en 2019
et et en 2020
il s'est débordements inacceptables
mettent en péril une liberté primordiale
dans une grande démocratie la liberté de
manifester vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le Président liberté constitutionnelle
liberté qui appartient à tous nos
concitoyens je rappelle la France
évidemment est un État de droit et c'est
son honneur
dans lequel chacun est libre d'exprimer
ses opinions
et même j'en suis convaincu libre
d'exprimer sa désapprobation
face à des réformes gouvernementales et
je suis de ceux qui pensent que la
richesse d'un pays se mesure aussi à la
diversité bien sûr
et la force des convictions de ses
concitoyens
défendre ses idées ses opinions toujours
été pour moi le signe
tangible d'un engagement citoyen
mais qui ne peut et ne doit s'inscrire
que dans le respect le plus absolu de la
règle commune qui est la loi
dans notre
démocratie la loi
n'est pas le fruit d'un coup d'état ou
dont je ne sais quel dérive autoritaire
la loi en France et le résultat d'un
processus démocratique
aboutit
qui commence par des élections
transparentes et qui se terminent par le
contrôle d'une Cour constitutionnelle en
passant bien sûr bien sûr par une
procédure parlementaire où tout le monde
est en particulier les oppositions
et doivent le faire
non ce qui est pas acceptable dans un
état de droit c'est que l'exercice de la
liberté d'expression soit
instrumentalisée détourné
pour se livrer à des exactions pourtant
atteinte aux personnes évidemment de la
plus légère la plus grande
au pillage des biens ou saccage de
l'espace public
qui sont les auteurs et les membres
actifs de ces groupuscules violents
nous savons aujourd'hui que certains
débordements sont le fait d'individus
en lien les uns avec les autres sur les
réseaux sociaux
animés de la même intention de
déstabilisation des forces de sécurité
qui se rencontrent sur regroupe
s'agrègent parfois jusqu'à former ce
qu'on appelle un black bloc
ou qui
redoutable du passage à l'acte
une partie des activistes se distingue
par des modes d'action spécifique
mode d'action violent
et d'autres actions ont pour but
d'infiltrer des mouvements
revendications par ailleurs disons-le
légitime
sur des sujets
écologistes sociétaux
et
se traduisent par leurs cours
systématique et la violence
quant à elle bien sûr toujours toujours
illégitime contre les forces de sécurité
intérieure et ce type d'action appelle
un traitement judiciaire
adapté
c'est également que sur les 3100 89
garde à vue porter à la connaissance de
mon ministère et pris sur l'ensemble du
territoire
91% des gardes à vue étaient des
majeures
puis ce n'est pas tout à fait votre
périmètre mais je me permets d'apporter
cette précision
se distingue des émeutes que nous avons
connues postérieurement
où là on trouve beaucoup beaucoup de de
jeunes de jeunes hommes et même de très
jeunes mineurs
et ça nous renseigne ses premiers
enseignements que nous avons sur la
physionomie de ces groupes alors comment
lutter contre la délinquance de ces
mouvements violents
en tant que guerre des sons il
m'appartient de mobiliser évidemment
l'ensemble des acteurs judiciaires de la
chaîne pénale
avec des directives claires
reposant sur une politique pénale
lisible cohérente
et je le revendique empreinte de fermeté
pour réprimer ces violences de la
manière la plus efficace
et si notre arsenal législatif permet
d'appréhender les comportements violents
donc toute leur manifestations la
répression de ces phénomènes peut encore
être renforcée par une meilleure
identification des membres les plus
actifs de ces mouvements subversifs
alors
vous l'avez dit d'une certaine façon ce
président cette
identification s'avère difficile
et elle est aussi difficile qu'elle est
naturellement indispensable à
l'effectivité de la réponse pénale
car on va le rappeler
dans un état de droit il faut d'abord
des preuves pour condamner un individu
cette
identification est d'abord difficile
parce que ces individus agissent à
visage couvert
mais également parce qu'il est pas
toujours possible de les interpeller au
moment du passage à l'acte
les forces de l'ordre étant mobilisées
dans le rétablissement de l'ordre public
dualité ou contradiction entre
l'intervention dans le cadre
administratif et et l'intervention dans
dans le cadre judiciaire et le recours
le plus important des moyens techniques
tels que les produits de marquage codés
peuvent s'avérer un outil précieux dans
Recueil des preuves
en ce qu'ils offrent la capacité
d'objectiver la présence d'un individu
sur une zone déterminée
évidemment
des investigations au long cours sont
conduites
postérieurementaux aux agissements
violents ou pillages pour parvenir à
l'identification au plus près bien sûr
du passage à l'acte des auteurs qui
n'auraient pas pu être interpellé sur le
champ
et outre ses actions je veux également
souligner l'importance que revêt
aujourd'hui
le partage du renseignement entre tous
les acteurs de la chaîne pénale la
coordination de tous les partenaires
locaux
est indispensable des services de
renseignement territoriaux à l'autorité
préfectorale en passant bien sûr bien
sûr par les procurants dans la
République c'est le sens de la lettre
que j'ai adressé le 22 juin dernier à
mon collègue ministre de l'Intérieur
pour lui indiquer qu'une action commune
efficace
repose nécessairement sur l'implication
des services de renseignements
territoriaux lesquels en pour mission
d'une part de signaler au parquet les
situations des membres les plus actifs
de ces réseaux afin que l'autorité
judiciaire
puisse envisager le cas échéant la
judiciarisation
de leur situation sur le fondement des
qualifications infraction mobilisable et
d'autre part de participer aux instances
partenariales thématiques susceptibles
d'être initié par les parquets afin de
vrai
continuum de sécurité indispensable et
de développer une réponse plus adaptée à
ses agissements
je soutiens ce président mesdames
messieurs qu'une approche
proactive peut-être développée par
l'autorité judiciaire
afin d'appréhender par un travail
conduite en amont
des événements sans attendre certains
débordements
au fond j'évoque là une anticipation les
individus les plus virulents et les plus
actifs qui forment des projets d'action
ciblées d'une particulière violence des
qualifications pénales appropriées
peuvent en effet être mobilisés pour
appréhender les individus qui appellent
à la violence ou encore qui
accomplissent des actes préparatoires au
soutien de leurs projets d'action
violente au cas par cas en fonction des
agissements en présence et des éléments
probatoires à disposition des parquets
ces infractions peuvent prendre la forme
d'appel à la violence de menaces de
commettre un crime un délice sur une
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique voire de constituer des actes
préparatoires à la commission d'une
action violente
identifiée susceptible de tomber sous le
coude la qualification
d'associations de malfaiteurs
dans leur mission de recueil
d'informations à l'égard des profils les
plus actifs susceptibles d'être porteur
d'une menace pour l'ordre public
les services de renseignement ont
vocation à livrer les éléments à
l'autorité judiciaire
dont la judiciarisation pour intervenir
s'ils sont révélateurs de l'engagement
de ces individus dans un processus
délictuel ça nécessite pour l'autorité
judiciaire de développer une approche
fine éclairée
disons-le lucide des situations pour
parvenir à isoler les individus les plus
virulents des fauteurs de troubles
spontanés
qui projettent la commission de telles
actions dans le contexte de rassemble de
rassemblement d'ampleur c'est le sens
des directives du ministère de la
Justice qui prend également toute sa
part en déployant je l'ai dit une
politique pénale empreinte de fermeté et
de célérité
et depuis
2018 ce sont près de cinq circulaires et
des pêches
qui ont été diffusés auprès des parquets
généraux et parquet locaux afin
d'attirer leur attention sur le
traitement qui doit être réservé à ces
faits tant en amont des manifestations
afin de minimiser les débordements en
favorisant les chances d'information que
pendant ces manifestations
face aux événements du Printemps 2023 la
direction des affaires criminelles des
grâces a diffusé dès le 18 mars 2023 une
dépêche la tension des parquets généraux
et locaux
relatives au traitement judiciaire des
infractions commises à l'occasion des
manifestations ou des regroupements en
lien avec les contestations contre la
réforme des retraites en réponse à ces
événements d'une ampleur disons
exceptionnel
porteur d'une désorganisation d'une
déstabilisation inédite de notre État de
droit nous avons ainsi rappelé et appelé
à l'adaptation de l'organisation des
juridictions à la faveur d'un
renforcement des effectifs de magistrats
et de greffiers pour pouvoir répondre à
un autre objectif celui d'une réponse
pénale rapide
rendu possible par un recours accru au
déferlement lorsque les auteurs sont
identifiés que leur personnalité ou la
gravité des faits justifie une telle
réponse pénale cet appel mesdames et
messieurs les députés étaient suivis des
faits puisque sur les
3189 gardés à vue
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure majeur et
mineure confondus 618
ont été déférés et 14
ont été
traitées dans le cadre d'une information
judiciaire 312 auteurs par ailleurs été
poursuivis par les voies classiques de
la copj de la CRPC de l'ordonnance
pénale tandis que
494 personnes faisaient l'objet d'une
alternative aux poursuites je veux
souligner tout particulièrement
l'engagement de tous les magistrats
dégreffiers qui se sont mobilisés durant
plusieurs jours d'affilée afin de gérer
les garde à vue en nombre les
déferlements en quantité et les
audiences parfois tardives pour ne pas
dire très tardive tenu pendant les
événements du printemps dernier
leur action évidemment a été cruciale
dans
l'objectif qui était au fond
rétablir l'ordre républicain et je veux
ici profiter de l'occasion qui m'est
donnée pour les remercier
chaleureusement
l'effet du printemps dernier nous ont
amenés à réfléchir au moyen
permettant une meilleure appréhension
judiciaire des mouvances extrémistes
violentes
les infractions imputées assez
émouvantes commises en marge de
manifestations ou d'événements sportifs
ou culturels
doivent faire l'objet d'une appréhension
judiciaire rapide complète efficace afin
de prévenir ou de limiter les troubles à
l'ordre public susceptibles dans
résulter cet objectif est d'ailleurs
particulièrement d'actualité
au regard des enjeux attendus autour de
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
paralympique 2024 sur le territoire
national et plus près de nous
l'ouverture bientôt du Mondial de rugby
et au-delà de l'action proactive pouvant
être envisagée selon les modalités que
j'évoquais une réflexion a été engagée à
l'initiative de la Direction des
affaires communales et des grâces en
lien avec le parquet général de Paris et
le parquet de Paris
dans le prolongement de cette réflexion
des travaux conduits localement
procureur de la République de Paris a
indiqué à votre commission
qu'elle envisage la création d'un groupe
local de traitement d'adhélencance dédié
à la lutte contre les infractions
commises par les groupuscules violents
c'est instant c'est en effet susceptible
de constituer quand puis-je dire à un
cadre privilégié
d'échanges d'informations pour
appréhender encore davantage ces
mouvements et améliorer leur suivi par
une approche stratégique
et elle permet une sensibilisation de
chacun des acteurs et contribue à une
action concertée pour prévenir les
débordements et lutter contre les
infractions commises par les membres les
plus actifs de ces groupements
les réflexions conduites
nous amène
amène en outre le parquet de Paris
envisager une organisation spécifique
permettant un meilleur pilotage de
l'action des parquets traitement optimal
des affaires les plus complexes par des
magistrats dédiés et sensibilisés assez
problématique et comme j'ai pu vous
l'indiquer à quelques instants
il me semble indispensable que les
parquets concernés et notamment le
parquet de Paris puisse bien sûr dans le
respect du principe de proportionnalité
dont l'autorité judiciaire et garante et
toute la rigueur et l'exigence doivent
être les siennes sur le fondement de
renseignement partagé par les services
spécialisés
le parquet de pouvoir judiciarisé ouvrir
des procédures d'enquête ou
d'informations d'ailleurs en retenant
les qualifications adaptées
notamment
le délit participation et une
association de malfaiteurs lorsque les
renseignements recueillis
et le travail conduit par les services
de police permettent d'établir en amont
de l'infraction projetée la constitution
d'un groupement ou l'établissement d'une
entente c'est le texte en vue de la
préparation caractérisée par des actes
matériels tangibles d'une action
violente dirigée contre les membres des
forces de sécurité intérieure ou des
personnes déterminées
ces réflexions et plus largement cette
thématique
de faire l'objet d'une prochaine réunion
des procureurs généraux organisé à
l'automne par la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces au stade du
jugement
il ne fait aucun doute que des peines à
la hauteur de la gravité des faits
doivent être requises par le ministère
public pour permettre non seulement
sanctionner les auteurs de violence mais
également de les empêcher de commettre à
nouveau de telles infractions je pense
naturellement aux peines d'interdiction
de participer aux manifestations ou de
paraître en certains lieux je pense
également bien sûr à l'interdiction de
séjour
lorsqu'elles sont prononcées le respect
de ces peines doit être contrôlé pour
pouvoir en cas de violation de ces
interdictions être sanctionné
je termine
maintenant et je veux dire à ce propos
du contrôle que personne n'ignore que le
suivi de ces interdictions pose en
pratique la question des moyens
il nous faut en effet pouvoir suivre de
près les situations de ces manifestants
pour pouvoir établir une éventuelle
violation dans l'interdiction ça
nécessite des moyens humains matériels
indéniable indispensable à la
satisfaction de notre objectif commun
celui de la lutte contre ces violences
insupportables et c'est notamment l'un
des objectifs de la loi de programmation
adoptée par les deux assemblées qui sera
examinés prochainement par
commission mixte paritaire en conclusion
monsieur le Président
je veux dire que la justice a été à la
hauteur de sa mission en réprimant de
façon fermée rapide ces violences et
tout en respectant bien sûr notre État
de droit
tous
magistrables fonctionnaire de greffe
mais également à Jean pénitentiaire de
la probation judiciaire de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse membre de
l'administration centrale tout le monde
a été pleinement mobilisé
pour que
la justice passe dans ce contexte
extrêmement difficile et extrêmement
tendu et vous le voyez mesdames et
messieurs les députés l'engagement du
ministère de la Justice dans la lutte
contre les violences commises par ces
groupuscules et total tant pour les
réprimer que pour s'adapter avec de
nouvelles méthodes et de nouveaux moyens
je me tiens
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
à votre disposition pour répondre aux
questions que vous voudrez bien me poser
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
évidemment je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur mais dans votre
intervention vous avez aussi évoqué la
question évidemment des moyens
vous avez
mentionné à plusieurs reprises la
situation parisienne et fort fort
légitimement nous étions hier à
Sainte-Soline et par voie de conséquence
nous avons aussi pu voir comment dire à
la fois les difficultés qui étaient
posées très très spécifiquement en fait
l'une des difficultés concerne par
exemple un tribunal judiciaire comme
celui de Niort qui n'a évidemment on
peut le dire ainsi pas l'habitude
d'avoir à faire face à je dirais une une
telle arrivée massive de de cas à
traiter et donc est-ce que alors en plus
c'est assez il faut bien dire c'est
assez imprévisible puisque vous ne savez
pas à quel endroit en milieu rural de
telles difficultés peuvent apparaître en
tout cas nous avons eu une présentation
par le général de gendarmerie
responsable de la zone de gendarmerie
qui a montré que comment dire
heureusement il y a cette maille très
large qui permet de redéployer aussi des
moyens une échelle bien au-delà du
niveau départemental et donc la question
qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'il y a
actuellement à la Chancellerie des
travaux pour en quelque sorte pardon de
du parallèle mais ce qu'on appelle par
exemple à l'éducation nationale des
titulaires de zone de remplacement
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il y a des
réflexions pour pouvoir amener à un
moment précis un appui un tribunal
judiciaire qui aurait à faire face à
surcroît très considérable d'activité
pour justement faire en sorte que les
objectifs que vous avez indiqués
respectez et déf endre évidemment l'État
de droit mais aussi faire en sorte que
la réponse pénale soit rapide puisque en
fait l'une des questions l'une des
attentes très fortes c'est une réponse
pénale rapide si vous pouviez juste
donner quelques éléments sur ce point là
et puis ensuite comme je vous
l'indiquais je passe évidemment la
parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur
naturellement j'oublie pas de répondre
aux questions que vous m'avez
initialement posées mais
[Musique]
d'abord je veux faire remarquer j'ai une
partie de mon propos liminaire
qui se fonde sur l'impérius nécessité
de ne perdre aucune information si je
dis
pas exclusivement dans le but de
judiciariser mais aussi dans le but de
judiciaire service de renseignement et
vous évoquez le juridiction de Niort il
y a eu une anticipation parce que l'on
savait évidemment qu'il y aurait un
certain nombre de manifestations et un
afflux massif de participants
certains disons-le
bien intentionnés dans une contestation
il y a pas grand chose à dire et les
forces de l'ordre on va le redire était
là aussi pour protéger les manifestants
puis d'autres qui sont venus pour casser
moi je suis Dieu qui pense que on
traverse pas la campagne avec des boules
de pétanque des explosifs des haches etc
etc on traverse la campagne j'ai une
vision plus bucolique de la promenade
que l'on peut faire dans les champs
petite parenthèse que j'ouvre et que je
referme mais je veux dire que le
fonctionnement ne doit pas être un
fonctionnement en silo et pardon mais
l'époque me conduit à dire d'ailleurs
que dans d'autres domaines que celui-là
et pardon si je sors un peu de votre
saisine les pôles spécialisées violences
faites aux femmes c'est la même chose ce
que nous faisons c'est d'essayer de
rapprocher les différents partenaires
pour ne plus qu'il y ait de perte
d'informations parce que c'est toujours
au préjudice de la justice évidemment et
et des victimes et donc il y a eu cette
préparation en amont et puis
il y a une souplesse naturellement pour
répondre très directement à votre
question qui permet la délégation de
membres d'un parquet vers j'allais dire
un autre parquet qui va connaître une
situation d'urgence parquet et siège
d’ailleurs et moi je ne suis pas alors
pas du tout opposé est-ce que on puisse
encore travailler sur ces questions
d'ailleurs vous savez que mais là on
sort un peu du périmètre métropolitain
si j'ose dire mais on a envisagé aussi
des brigades de l'urgence vous le savez
pour envoyer en urgence sur des
territoires qui connaissent des
problèmes d'attractivité je pense à
Mayotte par exemple je pense un Cayenne
des magistrats et des greffiers pour
aller en urgence aider la justice locale
donc
je suis dans cet état d'esprit je lirai
évidemment avec beaucoup d'attention
votre votre rapport et pourquoi pas
continuer à travailler sur ces questions
et envisager encore davantage de de
mobilité de flexibilité
un terme qu'on utiliserament en matière
de justice mais pour que justement dans
les situations d'urgence dans les
petites juridictions on puisse
régler cette question et en tous les cas
mieux l'anticiper
d'ailleurs dire
que dans le ressort de la Cour d'appel
de Poitiers
on doit envoyer 33 magistrats 39
greffiers 28 attachés de justice en
espérant naturellement que plus rien ne
se reproduise
ou dans le ressort de la Cour d'appel de
Poitiers ni d'ailleurs dans les autres
je voulais vous vous donnez cette
cette précision et naturellement tout ça
se déclinera sur un temps long enfin
vous vous le savez aussi bien que moi
tout cela est prévu à l'horizon bien sûr
2027 puisque c'est la loi de
programmation
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre pour
ces précisions donc je vais passer la
parole à Monsieur Florent Boudier donc
qui rapporteur de notre commission
d'enquête chers collègues vous avez la
parole ce ministre si vous pouvez juste
éteindre votre micro pour que notre
rapporteur puisse lui s'exprimer et puis
évidemment vous pourrez le rallumer pour
reprendre la parole dans la foulée
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le garde
des sceaux vous on reprend à la rentrée
parlementaire avec vous c'est une très
bonne chose devant la commission
d'enquête et je j'en profite pour saluer
nos collègues membres de la commission
d'enquête vous avez commencé vos propos
monsieur le ministre en rendant un
hommage appuyé aux forces de l'ordre
je fais une remarque devant les
collègues membres de la commission
d'enquête nous étions hier à
Sainte-Souline cela a été dit par
Monsieur le Président à l'instant
il y a en effet parlé d'individus
violents d'affrontement
lorsque l'on est sur place et que l'on a
un constat physique de la situation
géographique nous aurons l'occasion de
mes chers collègues d'en reparler mais
il apparaît un constat très simple c'est
qu'il n'y a pas d'affrontement possible
avec les forces de l'ordre s'il n'est
pas organisé
prémédité
et lorsque
6 millions 6 tonnes pardon 6 tonnes de
pierre sont par exemple accumulés
ça n'est pas pour reprendre votre propos
pour imaginer des constructions
bucoliques mais évidemment ce sont des
armes par destination pensée comme-elle
avec toutes les conséquences pour
l'intérêt physique et la vie de nos
forces de l'ordre que l'on peut imaginer
donc bien sûr je vais dans le sens de
vos propos j'ajoute vous le savez
monsieur le ministre que a lieu très
prochainement
un procès
et n'avons pas à commenter évidemment
les conditions dans lesquelles se
déroule je peux par contre nous
permettrait une remarque sur la pression
exercée sur les magistrats
c'est dans quelques heures
pression à l'encontre des magistrats du
parquet comme des magistrats du siège
dénonçant par avance
que toute décision
qui n'aboutirait pas de simples amendes
seraient par conséquent la traduction
d'une justice par essence politique
voilà je tenais mes chers collègues en
cette reprise de notre commission de
dénoncer de tels agissements de tels
propos peut-être voulez-vous ajouter
j'aurai quelques questions à vous poser
juste un point là-dessus si vous me
permettez monsieur le ministre pour pour
rebondir c'est vrai que hier sur place
qui nous a étonné c'est par exemple des
titres de la presse locale qui indiquait
que si les peines prononçaient étaient
supérieurs à on devait considérer qu'il
s'agissait en réalité d'un procès
politique donc enfin et d'ailleurs avec
l'un des titres qui était de dire projet
politique et donc on voit bien que là il
y a une comment dire une
un glissement qui qui peut très très
vite être dangereux puisque on cherche à
déconnecter la matérialité de fait avéré
pour pour différentes raisons et c'est
vrai que ça nous a sur le rapporteur
insistait sur ce point ça nous a
évidemment étonné et d'ailleurs avec
aussi une sorte de logique consistant à
dire mais est-ce que votre commission
d'enquête finalement elle ne va pas
simplement produire un autre récit et
qu'on serait dans une sorte de récit
contre récit alors que je tiens une
nouvelle fois insister le rôle d'une
commission d'enquête et de tout faire
pour objets
les choses elle est le plus près
possible du réel même si évidemment il
peut y avoir des éléments
d'interprétation et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle les rapports
permettent aussi aux différents groupes
parlementaires d'avoir leur propre
apport dans ce dans ce rapport mais
j'insiste une nouvelle fois qu'une
commission d'enquête cherche à
objectiver et pas simplement à produire
un autre récit comme si on était dans
une sorte de récit contre récit pardon
mais c'est vrai que ça nous a
particulièrement étonné hier pour ne pas
dire plus mais je vous laisse la parole
monsieur le ministre
rouge ça marche
ça marche
pour tout vous dire mais j'en ai
ras-le-bol ras-le-bol de cette petite
musique
de laisse désobéissance civile bon on
sait d'où ça vient
très clairement dénoncé c'est même
revendiqué on a le droit aujourd'hui
semble-t-il dit certains quand on est
porteur du d'une cause que l'on estime
légitime de ne plus obéir à la loi
c'est infernal et je le dis très
clairement
rien n'est plus liberticide que cela
donc il est vrai qu'au fond la liberté
d'abord ma liberté s'arrête ou commence
la vôtre et puis deuxièmement comme l'a
dit Jean-Jacques Rousseau la liberté
c'est obéissance à la loi commune
rien d'autre que ça
alors quand on n'est pas content
de l'inaction
gouvernementale en matière d'écologie on
peut aller fracasser des oeuvres d'art
bah tiens donc
sainte solide moi je vais quand même
rappeler les choses très clairement et
là on est dans de la chose publique bien
sûr
je suis évidemment monsieur le
rapporteur très soucieux comme vous de
l'indépendance totale de la justice et
je ne veux pas naturellement
constitution de l'interdit c'est très
bien comme ça interférer dans des dans
des affaires en cours sainte Soline
témoin il y a eu des concertations avec
les élus pour ces bassines après on peut
contester ne pas contester on a le droit
peut aller manifester si on déclare la
manifestation si on ne déclare pas on
n'est pas dans les clos bien et vous
avez des forces de l'ordre qui viennent
là à la fois pour protéger les
manifestants
et également pour protéger un objet en
l'occurrence cette bassine cette méga
bassine qui a fait l'objet de
concertation préalable
et voilà des gens qui sont
gravement blessés voilà des camions de
gendarmerie
qu'on brûle des
des gens qui ont traversé l'Europe
pour abonder cette horde de de type qui
ne respecte rien
moi je suis très choquée par ça quelques
jours à Aurillac
une dame a été interpellée
la gendarmerie ou la police peu importe
le procureur envisagé une ordonnance
pénale
dans les temps qui sont sont suivis
manifestations mille personnes
m'a-t-on dit pour protester contre
la brimade ainsi infligée par le parquet
et vous savez à quoi ce sont des prix au
drapeau
on a tagué la façade du tribunal
d'Aurillac on est rentré on a tout
fracassé
on a tout fracassé
le change qui est le lieu où on
accueille le justiciable ça c'est le
premier contact de nos compatriotes avec
la justice t'es mis par terre fracassée
les vitres les ordinateurs
le système de vidéo conférence par terre
et il s'en est fallu de quelques
instants que cette juridiction ne soit
totalement détruite par l'incendie qui a
été allumé par ces gens qui se coin tout
permis et moi je pense que tous ensemble
tous ensemble si on est respectueux de
notre démocratie on doit s'interdire me
semble-t-il
[Musique]
se laisser faire cette scandaleuse
musique qui consiste à dire mais vous
avez raison allez-y fracassez tout vous
vous êtes vous êtes dans les clous vous
avez le droit
non
et il y a je le dis
des incendiaires dans dans le monde
politique
et voilà et voilà où nous en sommes
sur monsieur le rapporteur la question
de
l'après méditation
sans doute
moi je traverse pas toute la France avec
des boules de pétanque et une hache et
des explosifs dans mon sac si je me
rends quelque part surtout pour une
promenade je le redis bucolique parce
que c'est ce que nous avons vu donc la
difficulté c'est de l'appréhender et
c'est toute la question probatoire que
j'évoque dans mon dans mon propos et la
nécessité d'avoir recours mais encore
faut-il qu'on puisse le faire à
l'infraction d'association de
malfaiteurs encore un mot là
sur les pressions exercées sur les
magistrats
d'abord les magistrats
ne sont pas sensibles aux pressions
ils sont indépendants
indépendants du pouvoir politique c'est
formidable et ça ne doit pas changer
parce que c'est ça
l'État de droit et l'un des critères de
l'État de droit on peut critiquer une
décision de justice en peine pas être
d'accord on peut voilà ok tout ça mais
mais la justice elle est indépendante et
le jour où il garde des sceaux on pourra
décrocher son téléphone pour dire dans
cette affaire jugé comme si jugit comme
ça ce sera fini de la démocratie mais ça
s'applique à tout le monde ce respect
que l'on doit à l'institution judiciaire
je l'ai dit à propos d'événements
récents
personne je dis bien personne ne peut
exercer de pression personne
et au fond
une décision est prise certains
s'arrogent le droit
d'exercer des pressions sur l'autorité
judiciaire
on a alors
on va dire les choses très clairement
les magistrats ils sont pas sensibles
aux pressions
inquiétez pas ils vont ils vont
évidemment résister à tout ça mais dire
par anticipation et porter cela avec une
parfois une résonance publique
qu'au-delà d'une certaine peine
c'est plus de la justice mais c'est de
la je sais pas quoi
ce qui se fait dans les pays qui sont
des dictatures c'est quand même c'est
quand même insupportable on devrait tous
je dis bien tous condamnés des propos
comme cela non
moi je crois enfin
[Musique]
je sais pas bien tous ces gens qui
pensent que nous avons basculé dans le
liberticide je les invite à aller faire
un petit tour à l'étranger il y a
quelques pays je pourrais leur dire à
l'oreille que je leur suggère de visiter
enfin quand même faut arrêter quoi il
faut arrêter de raconter ses salades ça
fait un mal de chien
comme vous voulez que sur des esprits
fragiles
faibles
pardon mais quand on est jeune
adolescent on a tous été un peu rebelle
voilà quand on met ça dans le tuyau de
l'oreille d'un gamin
au-delà de 500 balles d'amende on est on
a basculé dans la dans la dictature
judiciaire la justice est politique pas
demandé à ses gamins d'aller revoir Z de
Costa-Gavras ils auraient une vraie idée
de ce qu'est la justice politique mais
enfin faut arrêter ces conneries c'est
un supportable ça
insupportable non la police ne tue pas
la police nous protège non la justice
n'est pas politique non
et qu'elle ne le soit jamais
voilà ce que je veux dire avec véhémence
parce que j'en ai marre vous avez des
gens là qui se croient autorisés et et
d'ailleurs sur des affaires totalement
différentes prendre la parole
publiquement pour dire mais qu'est-ce
que c'est de ce truc et il faudrait s'il
faudrait la justice il faut elle a
besoin je l'ai dit de d'indépendance
et c'est un des rôles du garde des
sceaux que d'assurer cette indépendance
elle a besoin de sérénité
voilà
j'en viens ce président ce que
je me calmer un peu aux deux premières
questions que vous m'avez posées trouver
l'apaisement mais il faut dire les
choses parfois comme elle mérite d'être
dites moi je pense pas qu'il y ait de
contradiction entre l'administratif et
le judiciaire mais une forme de
complémentarité
d'abord on va rappeler que
l'organisation des services de police et
de gendarmerie
c'est la tutelle du ministre de
l'intérieur avec lequel sur ces
questions je dite de façon très claire
je suis totalement en phase mais
circulaire ont rappelé d'ailleurs la
nécessité
de participer à des réunions
préparatoires
parquet police préfecture etc ce que
j'ai dit à de multiples reprises je n'y
reviens pas
[Musique]
et puis le le développement de aux côtés
des policiers chargés du maintien de
l'ordre et rompu aux enquêtes
judiciaires
j'ai effectivement demandé à ce que il y
est c'est indispensable rapprochement on
ne peut pas je pense qu'on ne le fait
pas aujourd'hui fonctionner en silo ça
n'est pas possible
et ce qui a besoin de de réforme
procédurale
bon il y en a eu déjà un certain nombre
à la suite des dernières émeutes
on n'a pas eu de remonter à vrai dire
monsieur le Président sur des lacunes
textuelles et je peux vous dire que
de façon proactive si nous avions vu le
sentiment qu'il nous manquait quelque
chose
nous aurions immédiatement combler ce
vide mais je le redis sans flagornerie
le travail de co-construction que
j'essaie de conduire depuis que je suis
guère des sceaux avec le Parlement
m'amène à vous dire que naturellement je
serai très attentif aux préconisations
de votre rapport
rien n'est interdit pas les choses sont
pas figées
il faut qu'on continue à améliorer tout
ça parce que il y a des phénomènes je
les dis et puis cette petite musique de
la désobéissance civile bon je sais pas
si je suis pas d'accord je vais pas
saccager une toile dans un musée et
pourtant je suis pas d'accord avec tout
vous voyez voilà comme comme chacun
d'entre nous mais bon
sur les peines complémentaires
d'interdiction de séjour de paraître de
manifester je rappelais la dépêche mais
je l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure du du 18
mars 2023
qui rappelle l'intérêt de ces peines
complémentaires
interdiction de manifester ça peut être
pendant trois ans
et en 2019 il y a eu 340 interdictions
de manifester prononcés en 2022 il y a
200 un peu plus de 200 interdictions
prononcées
que je voulais vous préciser
naturellement le questionnaire que vous
m'avez adressé les plus précis bien sûr
j'entends il y a un certain nombre de
chiffres qu'on doit vous
communiquer et comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure ça arrive très vite
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
vais aussi passer la parole aux
collègues membres de la commission
d'enquête donc qui souhaitent s'exprimer
donc monsieur taverne joue je vous en
prie pour pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord je voudrais quand même attirer
votre attention que vous avez apporté
votre soutien aux forces intérieur et je
pense que comme vous l'avez dit
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale devrait le faire ce qui n'est
pas le cas de certaines
entité politique et
c'est force de sécurité intérieure ont
bien besoin et
c'est vrai que quand nous sommes allés à
Sainte-Souline hier je pense que
certains auraient dû faire le
déplacement puisque quand on voit que il
n'y avait pas seulement des couteaux des
cutter il y avait des poignards des
machettes des haches donc venir
manifester en toute
simplicité avec des armes perforantes
tranchant contondantes ça pose quand
même véritablement question donc il faut
rappeler véritablement notre notre
soutien aux forces de l'ordre alors ma
question porte sur la qualification
judiciaire qui est systématiquement
retenu puisque comme vous l'avez dit il
y a de l'après méditation
quand on vient avec
des armes quand on prépare six tonnes de
pierre il y a toute une organisation et
quand on entend les forces de l'ordre et
le elles sont interpellées justement par
la qualification judiciaire durant avec
armes
pour des gens qui qui ont un dispositif
une préparation tactique une stratégie
ça pose véritablement question
il y a également le traumatisme
envers
les les habitants les élus qui est
émus
un maire nous disait il y a eu des
pressions sur les habitants il fait des
gens cagoulés qui arrivaient dans un
petit village où il se passe rien
imaginez le traumatisme des habitants
qui qui n'osaient même plus sortir de
chez eux donc aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que quand il y a
des agressions de ce genre envers les
forces de l'ordre
qu'il devrait y avoir
une qualification beaucoup plus
importante
notamment par exemple une tentative de
meurtre puisque quand on balance des des
pavés des boules de pétanque sur sur des
policiers des gendarmes mais c'est pour
les tuer véritablement pour les tuer et
là-dessus je voudrais également monsieur
le Président rebondir sur la proposition
de loi de Naima muchour rappelez-vous
pendant la niche parlementaire de
d'horizon est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pensez que cette proposition de loi
aurait été
[Musique]
adapté à la situation puisque à la
rétablissait des peines minimales pour
les agressions envers les élus les
policiers et je pense qu'ils ont été
interpellés par votre opposition à cette
proposition de loi puisque aujourd'hui
quand on veut soutenir les policiers les
gendarmes on le fait de toutes nos
forces merci
la parole
je sais pas s'ils ont été émus par ma
réponse mais quand même vous dire très
très aimablement que elle a été un peu
instrumentalisée moi je vais vous dire
Monsieur
j'essaie
d'être
pragmatique et je pense que le bon sens
est une vertu cardinale
vous évoquez les peines plancher
par prétérition on n'avait pas prononcé
le mot mais on va y aller c'est pas un
mot tabou moi je dis deux choses là
dessus j'ai longuement exprimé
si j'avais la certitude que c'est
efficace
j'irai
mais ça n'est pas efficace parce que
nous l'avons déjà testé et ce que vous
appelez des peines plancher en réalité
ce n'est pas des peines plancher
pourquoi
parce qu'une peine plancher elle est pas
récent une vraie pleine plongée
c'est-à-dire que le juge a pas le choix
elle est par définition un
constitutionnelle
on a fait le tour de la question voilà
ce que j'ai dit donc ça n'est pas
méconnaître comment dirais-je le besoin
de fermeté exprimé par les forces de
sécurité intérieure ce n'est pas du tout
l'histoire la vraie peine plancher vous
dites demain voilà atteinte aux
policiers c'est tant et le juge n'a pas
le choix c'est un constitue scionnel
bien deuxièmement est-ce qu'on les a
testé oui est-ce que la délinquance a
baissé pendant la période non bah voilà
des raisons mais qui me servir de vous
faire remarquer puisque vous évoquez
cela et au fond la fermeté qui peut être
la mienne j'ai renforcé les pénalités
chaque fois que l'on s'en prend aux
forces de sécurité intérieure j'ai fait
en sorte dans un autre texte je sais pas
si vous l'avez voté
je suis pas convaincu mais peu importe
pas vous répondre sur le ton de la
polémique pour interdire que des grâces
soit
au bénéfice d'auteurs de fait contre les
forces de sécurité intérieure sur des
choses qui ont été faites très
clairement bien maintenant vous me posez
la question d'une façon un peu
singulière vous me dites
les qualifications la qualification elle
appartient d'abord au parquet et ensuite
au juge qui peut d'ailleurs modifier la
qualification retenue par le parquet
dans un sens ou dans l'autre à personne
d'autre c'est pas le Gard des sourds
vous savez les les films noir et blanc
regardez ceux des croches son téléphone
pour dire au procureur tremblant je
voudrais vous dire dans cette affaire ça
c'est fini terminé puis heureusement
d'ailleurs
parce que les juges ont acquis de haute
lutte leur indépendance et et ils en
sont particulièrement soucieux alors
dis pas que vous voudriez revenir à cet
état des choses qui est le nom je dis
pas ça mais
n'ayez jamais ces mauvaises idées
laissons faire la justice alors d'abord
les textes ils existent aussi et
vous-même la tentative d'homicide ça
existe si ça n'est pas retenu par le
parquet il y a bien quelques raisons à
cela les parquets au quotidien il
travaille comme ça avec les services de
police alors ensuite il y a des
expressions notamment on a entendu des
expressions syndicales contre lesquelles
je me suis toujours battu vous savez que
c'est peut-être pas mais j'étais invité
au beau de la sécurité je suis le seul
garde des sceaux qui a fait ça j'y suis
allé
j'ai rencontré toutes les organisations
syndicales et récemment j'ai inauguré
le l'ouverture du congrès annuel du
syndicat Alliance
qu'est-ce que je leur ai dit je leur ai
dit
vous avez tort de dire que le problème
de la police c'est la justice je veux
dire pourquoi vous avez tort de dire ça
s'il y a pas la justice qui contrôle
l'activité de la police
alors vous ne pouvez pas dire que la
police est républicaine
c'est
cette interaction police justice qui
fait que
et moi je n'aime pas quand j'entends des
expressions du problème de la police
d'ailleurs on l'entend de moins en moins
mais on l'a entendu et beaucoup un
certain moment et moi je disais nous
sommes dans la même barre que
républicaine et de la même façon qu'on
ne peut pas accepter que certains
oiseaux viennent nous dire que si on est
au-delà de l'amende c'est une justice
politique de la même façon on ne peut
pas entendre ce même discours tenu par
d'autres
respectons la justice et la grande
difficulté je vous le conseille
là-dessus vous jouez sur du velours
c'est que la présentation qui est faite
de la justice au quotidien c'est une
présentation fait diversiaire je
m'explique monsieur le député
une femme se fait tuer c'est un échec
absolu
et on dit une fois deux fois trois fois
dix fois 20 fois notamment au travers
des chaînes d'information continue
qu'elle s'est fait tuer
mais naturellement on ne dit jamais ce
que nous avons évité parce que nous
avons développé le bracelet anti
reprochement le téléphone grave danger
les ordonnances de protection on
travaille de façon constante sur ces
sujets sur ces questions et donc on
retient une femme s'est fait tuer et
derrière ça il y a mais que fait la
justice et la justice devient
responsable alors que la justice vous le
savez bien elle n'intervient d'une
certaine façon que quand le mal est fait
que la justice ne peut pas endosser une
éducation qui n'a pas été faite avec les
transmissions indispensables je parle là
de responsabilité parentale qui est un
sujet sur lequel je veux aller avec
lucidité beaucoup critiqué là-dessus
mais je redis moi à propos des émeutes
qu'un gamin de 11 ans n'a rien à faire
dehors qu'il faut tenir ses enfants bon
et puis ensuite évidemment l'éducation
nationale etc la justice intervient
n'ont pas en amont mais bien après tout
cela il y a une espèce de perversion des
choses qui
incite dans une espèce de mouvement
compte passionnel que je peux entendre
la justice est responsable de ça donc je
méfie moi tout ça oui justice il faut la
regarder beaucoup de recul beaucoup de
respect beaucoup de sérénité bien sûr
qu'elle peut se tromper évidemment mais
on peut se tromper au ministère le
Parlement peut se tromper
tous ceux qui font peuvent se tromper il
y a que ceux qui blablatent et qui
disent il y a qu'un faucon au soleil il
se trompe jamais mais c'est remarqué que
dans tous les domaines il y a 15 experts
à la douzaine dans tous les domaines qui
nous expliquent qui vous explique enfin
les gens qui bossent ils peuvent tous se
tromper donc un juge peut se tromper
bien sûr mais d'ailleurs la meilleure
démonstration de ce que un juge peut se
tromper c'est qu'il y a un appel
c'est qu'on peut interger à terre donc
il faut se méfier vous voyez de ces
cristallisations sur des affaires
précises pour cracher sur toute la
justice et moi je dis je dis que tous
les républicains devraient se garder de
critiquer la justice comme on fait
comment on fait là-bas pour ceux qui
n'osent pas envisager une autre peine
que celle qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
déterminé cela mais il y a tous les
autres
et et et
il faut se méfier de tout ça parce que
parce que tout ça est délétaire et que
ça nous fait finalement beaucoup de mal
donc voilà je pardon j'étais un peu long
je suis tenu aussi parler deux minutes
moi comment tuer donc parce que là j'ai
l'impression et coupable de les avoir
largement monsieur le Président dépassé
je me passionne pour ces choses parce
que j'essaie de défendre la justice en
sachant qu'elle a des défauts
mais attention c'est une grande
institution
pareil pour la police
si on a un régime à une équipe de
meurtriers
on n'est pas dans les clous de notre
belle démocratie je veux dire voilà
mais je vais passer la parole à Monsieur
le rapporteur et puis ensuite madame
Martinez monsieur Oudoul monsieur Caron
oui merci monsieur le Président je
partage vous propose monsieur le
ministre consiste à dire nous n'avons
pas accepté quel que soit les voix
concernées celles et ceux qui font
pression sur la justice et qui veulent
déterminer à la place même des juges les
décisions judiciaires que l'indépendance
leur impose de façon républicaine de
décider une question peut-être sur un
point que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé des de l'arsenal
législatif de son amélioration possible
et vous avez en particulier évoqué dans
votre intervention limitée
de marquage codé
on appelle ça aussi le marquage chimique
bon comment ça fonctionnerait dans votre
esprit ça intéresse évidemment la
commission d'enquête de regarder cette
proposition de près parce que soit on
est dans une phase amont et des
questions peuvent se poser sur la
liberté de manifester soit on est dans
la situation de violence s'exerçant et
auquel cas là on est dans la situation
plutôt d'identification des individus
violents est-ce que vous avez des
précisions à apporter à la commission
d'enquête monsieur le garde des sceaux
je peux répondre tout de suite je vous
en prie en fait c'est un outil chimique
qui permet une fois que
vous l'avez reçu de marquer cet
indélébile et ça permet d'avoir la
preuve que vous étiez présent oui
trouve pas forcément une culpabilité
c'est plus sur le terrain probatoire il
y a encore un travail accomplir parce
que si vous êtes un manifestant
tranquille et que vous êtes dans dans
une manifestation
avec avec comment dirais-je tout ce qui
caractérise une manifestation légale
sainte Soline il y a aussi cette
question de la légalité de la
manifestation voilà mais ça permet de
c'est un délibile vous pouvez pas
voilà et s'agissant de ces produits de
marquage avec la chronique on adore les
acronymes évidemment c'est le PMC
produit de marquage codé ça prend la
forme en réalité d'un liquide évidemment
inoffensif
projeté invisible à l'oeil
mais des Slaves uniquement par
fluorescence voilà
deux dépêches je vous ai très
précises en juin 2014 donc c'est un
vieil c'est un vieil outil déjà l'autre
en mars 2019
présentant évidemment l'intérêt
procédural de cette technique ainsi que
le cadre juridique applicable en espèces
monsieur rapporteur les articles 14
39-3 41 et 80 du code de procédure
pénale relatif au pouvoir d'enquête
généraux et ils ont été utilisés ces
produits lors des manifestations
antibacine des 25 et 26 mars 2023 à
Sainte-Soline
juste une précision on est dans le dans
le cadre donc de la consommation
puisqu'on a une difficulté c'est un
sujet qu'on traitera dans un rapport
d'ailleurs d'identification des profils
c'est-à-dire qu'on va bien que y compris
sur la communication
aux manifestants de bonne foi pour les
séparer de celles et ceux qui sont de
mauvaise foi
j'emploie des termes modérés on est bien
donc dans une phase post sommation de
dispersion pour pouvoir resserrer la
focale sur des individus supposés
prétendus violents
branché micro s'il vous plaît je vous
êtes prudent peut-être même que c'est un
excès de prudence parce que j'imagine
mal que l'on aspergea de ce produit des
gens qui se promènent tranquillement qui
sont dans la promenade de bucolique
telle qu'elle avait été décrite bon
mais c'est un bel outil qui permet de
voilà un type cagoulé par exemple que
vous l'asperger de ce produit inoffensif
je le redis pas qu'on s'inquiète ouais
naturellement on retrouve ensuite la
trace par un examen
d'un processus de fluorescence
qui d'un point de vue technique me
semble-t-il mais je suis pas un expert
ressemble un peu à ce que l'on appelle
le le Bluestar c'est à dire que c'est
pour le coup sont des un peu différents
mais sont des traces de sang qui sont
invisibles à l'oeil et qui sont révélés
par fluorescence
naturellement il faut le cadre ça va
s'en dire
merci beaucoup monsieur Miss donc je
passe la parole à Monsieur Odoul
pour deux minutes merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur le ministre nous partageons un
point de vue au-delà de notre soutien
pour les forces de l'ordre vous avez dit
vous en avez marre de la petite musique
de la désobéissance civile
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
et vous nous avez dit nous savons d'où
ça vient ma question elle est très
faible très claire d'où ça vient vous
nous aviez aussi il y a des incendiaires
dont le monde politique
propose extrêmement pertinents
j'aimerais vous poser la question très
simple qui sont ces incendiaires de les
nommer ce qu'il faut être précis ensuite
là où je vais avoir quelques oppositions
avec votre propos c'est que vous nous
avez dit la justice a été à la hauteur
de sa mission
malheureusement monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas le point de vue de l'immense
majorité de nos concitoyens et je ne
parle pas évidemment des sondages que
vous connaissez
73% des Français qui affirment que la
justice fonctionne mal 89% des Français
estiment que la justice est trop laxiste
mais si on prend les événements des
dernières manifestations réforme des
retraites et sainte Soline finalement ça
se vérifie
je vais prendre au-delà de l'exemple de
Sainte-Souline puisque j'ai pas pu être
avec les collègues hier et ça a été
commenté par d'autres mais si on prend
la manifestation et les manifestations
du premier mai
540 personnes ont été interpellées en
France près de 400 policiers blessés 400
policiers blessés pour le premier mai et
les condamnations vous avez seulement
deux hommes qui ont été condamnés voilà
donc vous voyez bien que la réponse
pénale que vous avez demandé
systématique et rapide il manquait à mon
sens un adjectif c'est ferme
et très clairement si la justice est
passée
si la justice est passée elle est passée
à côté et effectivement vous avez dit la
justice elle arrive toujours après elle
arrive toujours après et elle ne peut
pas enrayer le mal je suis d'accord avec
vous monsieur le ministre la justice ne
peut pas tout faire en revanche le rôle
de la justice c'est de faire en sorte
que le mal ne se répète pas ou en tout
cas qu'il se répète moins et comme la
justice n'est pas dissuasive et c'est là
le problème de votre politique de votre
philosophie depuis longtemps et ça s'est
révélé dans le cas de ces manifestations
le mal se répète
je vous en prie Monsieur le Ministre
et je vais me faire un plaisir de vous
répondre
pas certaine de vous convaincre parce
que vous êtes dans une posture
contrairement à moi
d'abord qui sont les incendiaires vous
savez qui a dit la politique
de l'extrême gauche moi je suis très
clair avec ça et votre question elle est
habile voudriez
que je vous donne
non pas l'extrême-onction mais l'onction
extrême au fond que je vous détache de
l'extrême gauche pour montrer à quel
point vous êtes vous sur ces sujets
des gens parfaits je pense pas du tout
je vais vous dire pourquoi
en fait vous faites votre miel
de ce que je dénonçais tout à l'heure ce
que j'appelle la fait diversification de
la justice par exemple
vous dites surtout les plateaux de télé
vous allez
que la justice et laxiste c'est faux
monsieur
tous les chiffres le démon je dis
bientôt qu'il s'agisse de la justice
criminelle rendue par la Cour d'assise
par des Français comme vous comme moi
il s'agisse de la justice corritionnelle
tous les chiffres le démon et le
troisième argument
c'est la surpopulation carcérale
dire dans ce pays que la justice et
laxiste quand on voit comment les
prisons sont remplies il faut oser mais
vous en faites votre miel
et vous n'arrêtez pas là-dessus et on a
beau vous contredire et dire au
Parlement je vous l'ai dit 20 fois je
les progresser vous votez maintenant les
moyens supplémentaires
vous étiez pas au rendez-vous de ces
obligations là chaque fois que je vous
répondais je dis vous êtes gentil de
cliquer la justice ouais qu'on nous a
demandé un peu de d'améliorer les
budgets vous étiez pas là ni justice ni
d'ailleurs force de l'ordre
vous vouliez pas bon bref
mais qui me soit permis de vous dire que
vous allez raconter ça partout autre
mensonge
autre inexactitude allez je vais être
magnanime vous dites les peines sont pas
exécutés dans ce pays il y a
combien 100000 peines pardon pour
l'impression qui ne sont pas exécutés
ces fonctions donc je vais vous
expliquer ce qui se passe
en réalité
quand on décerne un mandat de dépôt à
l'audience correctionnelle
la peine elle est immédiatement exécutée
vous voyez le type il arrive il est
condamné à 3 ans d'emprisonnement ferme
notre dépôt on lui remet les menottes et
il s'en va en prison quand c'est une
peine qui est aménageable et de ce point
de vue je voudrais vous dire que nous
avons été deux fois plus sévères que ce
qui existait autrefois puisque on
pouvait aménager une peine jusqu'à 2 ans
et nous nous avons fait en sorte
qu'elle ne soit plus aménageable
à deux ans mais à un an on a réduit par
deux on a été plus sévère
mais pour aménager monsieur Odoul il
faut réunir le SPIP il faut réunir le
juge d'application des peines service de
probation d'insertion pénitentiaire ça
prend du temps ça ne veut donc pas dire
que cette peine qui n'est pas
immédiatement exécutée n'est pas exécuté
ça veut dire monsieur quel est ton cours
d'exécution et quand elle est exécutée
elle sort de ce long de peine non encore
exécuté et d'autres peines sont arrivés
et cette masse de peine ce n'est pas une
masse de peine non exécutée c'est une
masse de peine en cours d'exécution je
l'ai dit une fois je l'ai dit deux fois
je les dis trois fois vous vous en
moquez vous voulez dire à nos
compatriotes parce que ça marche bien
parce que c'est très porteur sur le
terrain électoraliste que les juges
attendaient laissez-moi finir vous
m'avez posé une question je vous réponds
complètement que les juges sont affreux
laxistes
que les peines sont pas exécutés et que
naturellement tout ça va s'améliorer si
un jour vous arrivez au pouvoir voilà ce
que vous vendez mais qui me soit permis
de vous dire et je n'ai pas le don de
médiumetés que si un jour Monsieur Odoul
vous deviez arriver au pouvoir si un
jour ce que je ne crois pas ce que je ne
souhaite pas je vous donne pas deux
jours sans que vous ayez eu dans ce pays
des infractions des crimes parce que il
faut quand même que vous entendiez que
la criminalité est consubstantielle
bon j'ai encore vous donner d'autres
arguments ce que vous avez eu l'idée
monsieur le député d'aller voir ce qui
se passe ailleurs en Europe et comment
nous ne sommes pas mais loin sans faut
les derniers en termes de sévérité vous
ne faites pas ce travail vous dites
détient un malheur vous dit passer la
faute à la justice elle est laxiste
alors l'équipe il se croit tout permis
voilà ce que vous racontez sur les
plateaux de télé vous allez etc etc
maintenant je vais vous dire autre chose
je vous ai dit de façon un peu abrupte
confondez tout oui je veux dire vous me
donnez un nombre alors vous me dites 500
interpellations ça et puis peu de
condamnations mais dites moi voudriez
qu'on condamne des gens au bénéfice du
doute
c'est ça que vous voulez c'est ça votre
projet
reprenez la parole si vous voulez on
peut non mais parce qu'on nous regarde
aussi voyez on nous regarde là c'est
aussi l'utilité des choses c'est public
formidable non mais attendez votre
programme c'est quoi moi je dis mais ça
veut dire que la justice a fait le prix
parce que vous croyez que il y a un
magistrat ou parquet qui regarde la
procédure puis qui dit tiens du chemin
là il est coupable mais on va classer
sans suite on poursuit pas ou penser
franchement que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe mais c'est un jurieux à l'égard
des magistrats
un type est pas poursuivi monsieur le
député au double c'est parce que il y a
pas matière et ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
y a une responsabilité ou une carence
ni des services de police
service de police défaire des gens
pensent que et ensuite il y a tout un
travail vous n'accepteriez pas vous
d'être condamné sur un soupçon vous
exigeriez citoyen que vous êtes dans ce
grand pays quel autre qu'il y ait contre
vous des preuves de votre culpabilité
d'ailleurs le serment aux assis c'est
quels sont les preuves rapportées quels
sont les preuves apportées contre la
fusée quels sont les preuves bon il y a
pas de preuve on en tirait voilà mais ça
ne peut pas être un sujet polémique je
vais vous dire chacun doit être à sa
place les policiers font leur boulot
c'est un boulot très difficile moi je le
rends hommage comme vous j'ai entendu
les magistrats font un boulot très
difficile en toute indépendance
l'interpellation ça signifie pas une
condamnation et heureusement dites-moi
heureusement donc les chiffres
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
il manque un petit bout parce que il y a
des affaires qui sont partis à
l'information à l'instruction aussi pas
les résultats voilà moi je m'occupe pas
de de de du suivi individuel etc mais
voilà comment les choses fonctionnent
voilà des choses qui méritent d'être
dites donc au fond c'est le député je
vous remercie infiniment de m'avoir posé
cette question
passe la parole à Monsieur Caron pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver après cette période estivale
j'aurais deux questions si vous me
permettez de questions de temps
différent ça change tout seul
représentant de mon groupe et ce sera
une question par procuration pour la
deuxième
monsieur le ministre bonjour
et une fois n'est pas coutume je
voudrais commencer par vous remercier
pour les paroles que vous venez de tenir
en réponse à mes collègues du
rassemblement national merci d'avoir
débunker quelques fake news d'avoir
rappelé et nous serons à vos côtés sur
ce point-là que non le problème de la
police ce n'est pas la justice que non
il n'y a pas des peines dans ce pays qui
ne sont pas exécutés ou que d'avoir
appelé que non la justice n'est pas
particulièrement laxiste dans ce pays
maintenant nous pouvons aller sur ce qui
nous ce qui nous sépare et il y a
beaucoup de choses effectivement
qui nous opposent
vous avez par exemple manifester une
colère tout à l'heure lorsque vous avez
dit
à ces scandaleux il y a des voix qui
s'élèvent dans ce pays pour dire que
nous basculent leurions dans des lois
liberticides dans un état liberticide
dans un état liberticide on met ça dans
la tête des gamins bah non on met pas ça
dans la tête des gamins les gamins
l'expérimente en réalité lorsqu'on voit
par exemple les manifestations qui ont
suivi la réforme des retraites ces
gamins ils étaient dans la rue ils ont
essayé de manifester beaucoup d'entre
eux ont été arrêtés de manière
arbitraire ils sont retrouvés en garde à
vue de manière absolument illégale
libérée au bout de 48 heures après deux
jours d'humiliation et d'intimidation
pour justement qu'on leur explique bien
qu'il faudrait qu'ils évitent de
retourner comme ça manifester dans la
rue on a arrêté des gens qu'on avait
absolument pas arrêté tout simplement
parce qu'il était un endroit au mauvais
moment et au-delà de l'expérience que
ces jeunes gens ont pu vivre par
eux-mêmes ils écoutent également les
rapports de la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme de la Défenseur des droits les
manifestations des Nations Unies ceci
étant dit vous en êtes pris également
lors de votre intervention à la
désobéissance civile
quelle horreur quelle horreur la
deuxième la désobéissance civile pour
ceux qui nous écoutent tout juste
rappeler ce que c'est c'est le rejet
d'une loi d'un règlement qu'on trouve
injuste et qu'on va donc refuser
d'appliquer
et comment va le refuser d'appliquer par
une réaction de non-violence on va
essayer de trouver une action non
violente c'est le principe c'est Henri
David Toro c'est Gandhi alors on pourra
discuter est-ce que mettre de la
peinture sur un tableau opportun je
trouve pas mais sur le principe même je
fais partie de ceux qui soutiennent ce
principe donc ce sera ma première
question très direct
Rosa Parks 1955 elle refuse d'obir à la
loi elle refuse Rosa Parks de céder sa
place dans un bus un blanc elle est
arrêtée condamnée elle aurait pas dû le
faire au départ
tu voulais se poser la deuxième tout de
suite comme ça le garde
c'est ça votre première question
il y a des lois qui consacrent
l'apartheid chez nous
en Israël attendez alors vous m'avez
posé la question mais alors Monsieur
Caron vous me posez la question sur le
député souffrait que je vous réponde
d'abord je vais vous dire
vous dites
préambule singulier il me semble-t-il
que nous sommes d'accord sur un certain
nombre de sujet lesquels
la justice n'est pas le problème de la
police
immédiatement vous embryez en parlant de
choses qui auraient été faites qui
sont-ils légales qui étaient est-ce que
la justice
[Musique]
a condamné pour des guerres à vue qui
auraient été
faites dans l'île l'égalité par exemple
à votre connaissance
et des détentions arbitraires puisque
vous avez parlé d'arrestation arbitraire
vous avez des condamnations pour ça
ben oui de la justice c'est la justice
qui condense ces personnes d'autre oui
non mais bon d'accord
alors donc vous rendez hommage à la
justice mais vous trouvez qu'elle
contrôle la police donc c'est un hommage
singulier bon non mais attendez je vais
vous répondre
ah non c'est pas ce que vous m'avez dit
vous avez dit vous avez dit vous avez
dit vous avez dit dans votre propos
complet
moi j'ai non seulement des oreilles mais
j'ai une mémoire voilà souffrez que je
remette vos propos en perspective alors
certes comme j'ai dit de toute chose au
rassemblement national ça vous a
émoustillé mais pour le reste pour le
reste pour le reste pour le reste
c'est sûr que la condescendance ou ça
vous va bien et bon c'est sûr monsieur
monsieur Caron c'est d'ailleurs on
connaît votre modestie naturelle mais
souffrez souffrait que je vous souffrez
que je vous réponds ou alors de me poser
pas de question et et permettez-moi de
vous répondre
moi vous savez quand vous m'avez posé la
question j'ai pas dit un mot
j'aimerais que la réciproque soit vrai
non mais
non non
moi j'ai pas porté d'objection à votre
question je suis en train de le faire et
vous m'interdisez de le faire si
si donc maintenant c'est à moi qu'on a
donné la parole je vous réponds donc
curieux préambule que de dire que la
justice n'est pas le problème de la
police pour dire immédiatement que la
police
contre le mal que la justice contre le
mal la police bien
ça c'est la première des choses la
justice laissez-la tranquille et c'est
la travailler etc il y a des voies de
recours dans ce pays quand on n'est pas
content voilà
c'est une première remarque ensuite la
désobéissance civile dans la
non-violence dans la non-violence moi
rien ne me gêne vous voyez
mais dans la violence ça me gêne
beaucoup
et que par exemple au cours des émeutes
récentes
on n'est pas eu de condamnation
de gens qui sont vos alliés
sur les attaques contre les
commissariats contre les tribunaux il y
a une vingtaine de lieux de justice qui
ont été dégradés dont sur le président
des points justice les points justice
c'est ma petite fierté à moi vous voyez
c'est des lieux où on reçoit nos
compatriotes les plus modestes c'est
gratuit c'est confidentiels
c'est aider les gens ouais vraiment qui
qui ont du mal à s'orienter dans les
méandres judiciaires on est allé
fracasser ça il y a pas une condamnation
ah pardon souffrait d'entendre ma
réponse complètement
et puis de quoi vous me parlez monsieur
désobéissance civile vous avez un texte
en France qui consacre l'apartheid
vous vous l'avez vu en Israël la portée
d'ailleurs déposé un texte que vous avez
retiré immédiatement
oui oui oui je vais jusqu'au bout vous
le voyez partout mais mais quel scandale
de dire là
quel scandale d'aller aux États-Unis
dans la pire des périodes pour comparer
avec des textes qui seraient des textes
affirmant une privation de liberté la
négation des valeurs de de l'esprit de
l'esprit qui est le nôtre de du souffle
des lumières vous allez nous raconter ça
monsieur le député je vous en supplie il
y a pas de texte en France qui consacre
l'apartheid voyez
il y a des divergences sur l'écologie un
certain nombre de choses ont très bien
très bien
mais pour autant est-ce qu'on peut aller
dégrader une oeuvre d'art moi j'ai vu
des gens
arroser la Chancellerie j'étais présent
arrosé la Chancellerie avec la peinture
orange
c'est un mode d'expression ça mais
franchement c'est un mode d'expression
ça vous vous trouvez avec lui sans doute
mais moi je trouve que non
et puis à Sainte Soline puisqu'on
parlait de sainte Soline type il
traverse la France avec des armes dans
leur sac
je Mélanchon et d'ici le promenade dans
les champs bon c'est comme ça que vous
promenez dans les champs mais c'est
scandaleux tout ça alors vous voulez
vous les démolir la République en
réalité c'est ça et moi j'y tiens
viscéralement à la République
voilà ce qui fait divergence entre nous
donc je pense avoir répondu à votre
première question la désobéissance
civile non violente pas trop d'ailleurs
comment on peut désobéir à la loi la loi
c'est c'est ce qui nous unit vous voyez
c'est ce qui s'immense nos relations
c'est ce qui fait la Nation et dans le
cadre de la loi d'ailleurs il y a des
espaces de liberté la preuve les
questions que vous me posez pas interdit
de me les poser et puis je suis pas
interdit de vous répondre comme je
l'entends ben voilà mais allez faire un
tour ailleurs
et faire un petit tour ailleurs puis
vous verrez on est un pays absolument
extraordinaire et et et c'est nié par
des gens comme vous qui ne reconnaissent
rien jamais rien jamais rien de vous
voir donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise contester monsieur monsieur
monsieur monsieur monsieur le député
vous en avez le droit levez-vous dites
que tout ça n'est pas juste le droit de
vous exprimer
mais la loi c'est la loi et une fois
qu'elle est votée elle s'applique et oui
cette musique de la vous justifiez tout
même les Monsieur Mélenchon et même
justifié les attaques de Comé enfin il a
rien dit sur les attaques de
commissariat c'était plus subtil que ça
il a déploré les attaques contre les
écoles je trouve les commissariats au
tribunal Daniel
j'ai vu des gens les larmes aux yeux
vous savez ce qui jugeaient dans
l'après-midi ils ont pas pu le faire
parce que tout était saccagé il y a un
vigile qui a failli brûler là brûler vif
il juger du surendettement les gens les
plus modestes voilà c'est de la justice
de proximité alors vous pouvez dire que
c'est formidable moi je trouve ça
insupportable voilà
pour la deuxième question et puis on se
dit
désolé que vous n'ayez pas répondu à ma
question même si vous avez quand même
reconnu la pertinence de la
désobéissance civile sauf que vous y
avez ajouté un critère il faut que vous
choisissiez la loi qui peut être
combattue selon vous et ça c'est assez
dommage dommage aussi que vous ayez pris
une remarque qui était une remarque qui
se voulait tout à fait républicaine pour
en faire un moment politique ici qui
vous sert simplement à faire des effets
de manche pour dire regarder je m'en
prends la force insoumise je vais
certainement pas me laisser embarquer
dans des trucs alors que je pense que
nous sommes dans un moment politique ou
au contraire c'est le moment où on voit
les républicains et ceux qui ne le sont
pas et qui voudraient éviter ce genre de
sortie qui crée la confusion de ceux qui
nous écoutent
merci de le reconnaître
ma deuxième question on note depuis
plusieurs années une augmentation de la
répression à l'égard des militants
écologistes
[Musique]
dans votre ancienne vie vous avez été
amené à traiter des affaires extrêmement
délicates
vous avez défendu un homme qui a été
condamné pour association de malfaiteurs
en lien avec une entreprise terroriste
condamnée à un temps de prison en lien
avec l'une des affaires terroristes les
plus terribles les plus ignobles de ce
pays donc vous savez parfaitement ce que
c'est que le terrorisme
et ses conséquences donc j'aimerais vous
répondez très directement à cette
question
certains de vos collègues qualifient des
militants écologistes de terroristes
écho terroriste nouvelle nuance qui a
été inventée
qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous de
l'utilisation du terme terroriste
appliqué à des gens qui se battent pour
que une
par exemple une bassine ou en tout cas
une installation qui nuirait à notre
planète et bien pour que cette
installation n'est soit démantelée par
exemple
je vous repasse la parole monsieur le
ministre
j'entends que vous revenez sur mon
ancienne vie je sais qu'elle vous
préoccupe beaucoup vous n'êtes pas le
seul d'ailleurs
n'oubliez pas comme un reproche je suis
très fier de ce que j'ai fait comme
avocat puis pour dire les choses très
clairement monsieur le député j'ai
défendu mes rats et j'ai dit pourquoi je
l'avais défendu je l'ai dit parce que
s'il n'avait pas eu de défense il y a
pas beaucoup d'avocats qui se
bousculaient au portillon pour aller le
défendre alors je pense que les
terroristes aurait gagné parce que ce
qui distingue le terrorisme de notre
État de droit c'est justement la règle
de droit oui j'ai expliqué ça très
longuement
[Musique]
et je pense que c'est une réalité et le
vet 13 est
l'illustration ce procès remarquable
exemplaire
de ce que nous nous traitons pas
les accusés quel que soit le crime
qu'ils ont pu commettre
comme le ferait des terroristes qui
n'ont pas de règles qui n'ont pas de
procédure pénale qui n'envisage pas les
droits de la défense etc donc voilà
pourquoi j'ai été là dans une autre vie
si c'est ça que vous souhaitez me redire
me dire plus exactement où
éventuellement me reprocher
un monsieur a été condamné à un enferme
la justice est passée je commande ça
c'est curieux pour quelqu'un qui a de
cela quelques minutes souhaitait rendre
hommage à la justice au fond
et oui
oui écoutez je pense que ce monsieur a
eu droit à un moi je connais pas
l'affaire je pense qu'il a eu droit à un
procès équitable
que le ministère public s'est exprimé
que les magistrats en charge de le de le
juger ont estimé que sa culpabilité
devait être retenue qu'ils ont fixé la
peine qu'il croyait devoir fixer je ne
sais pas si ce monsieur interjeté appel
ou pas si c'est définitif s'il n'était
pas content il pouvait toujours
interjeter appel voilà sur le reste
pardon moi je n'ai pas à commenter des
propos que je n'ai pas tenus demandez à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur de
les commenter je pense qu'il vient dans
très peu de temps vous lui poserez la
question voilà
je n'ai pas à répondre à cette question
est-ce que je vous pose des questions
sur les propos tenus par Monsieur
Mélenchon par exemple
qu'est-ce que vous dites par exemple
quand quand
on joue à cela voyez-vous c'est toujours
très facile non mais attendez moi je
n'inverse rien ben voilà c'est reparti
[Musique]
d'accord
décidément je vois que vous scrutez mais
moindre faits et geste voilà il y a des
moments où on a envie
très bien et on le scrute et on le
laserrise d'une certaine façon vous avez
raison il m'arrive de faire de l'humour
mais là j'ai pas envie oui
je vais vous dire puis j'ai le droit de
pas avoir envie de faire du mot ça c'est
mon droit c'est ma liberté voilà je la
rebondis monsieur le député je veux dire
quelque chose non mais écoutez-moi bien
à ce jeu vous voyez d'abord ces mots on
peut être prononcés dans un certain
conteste il ne sortent pas de ma bouche
je ne les ai pas prononcés poser la
question à l'intéressait je pense que il
vous répondra sans aucun doute parce que
je pense qu'il assume ses propos il les
a d'ailleurs réitérer mais à ce jeu là
moi je ne vais pas vous opposer un
certain nombre de choses que j'ai
entendu dans la bouche de vos amis
politiques vous voyez ou de comportement
pardon
ah d'accord donc vous vous très bien
dont vous vous avez des droits que moi
je n'ai pas et ma réponse doit être doit
se plier à vos exigences bon
j'ai répondu
j'ai répondu monsieur Caron je suis
navré de ne pas vous satisfaire mais
j'estime avoir répondu voilà très bien
merci beaucoup je rappelle une nouvelle
fois que l'objectif d'une commission
d'enquête et de chercher à objectiver
faire en sorte que l'on aille le plus
proche possible de choses qui permettent
de là aussi de de cerner cette
problématique des violences je pense en
tout cas évidemment nous sommes dans une
enceinte ou les débats sont possibles je
pense que
c'est important en tout cas
ce ministre une nouvelle fois je vous
remercie pour pour votre présence mes
chers collègues merci à vous je vais
lever la séance et je vous indique que
nous reprenons donc dans cette salle
même à 14h cette fois-ci avec l'audition
des dirigeants des organisations
syndicales et pour bien préciser celles
qui ont des services d'ordre puisque en
réalité comme notre focale et d'avoir un
échange avec les organisations qui
peuvent justement être confrontés à des
problèmes d'organisation de leur propre
manifestations sans qu'il y ait de
développement de violence et ça sera
intéressant d'avoir ce regard de ces
organisations syndicales par rapport à
ce développement dont nous avons entendu
parler des pré-cortèges avec l'arrivée
de Black Bloc etc en tout cas merci
encore je lève la séance et donc retour
dans cette même salle à 14h pour celles
et ceux qui le pourront une nouvelle
fois merci infiniment monsieur le
ministre ainsi qu'à votre équipe et aux
membres de votre cabinet